the story of the biblical Jesus excuse
me the story of the biblical Jesus and
he's in the garden before they're coming
to arrest him what does he do he goes
off by himself and he kneels down and
puts his forehead to the ground and pray
earnestly praying that Christians don't
do that we do that we do that we follow
Jesus better than anyone does and we
shouldn't allow them it's it's like
current history today Barack Obama is
only half black so why do all these
white folks insult his mother and him
and his grandparents who raised him
you've got to understand we can't let
them take from us what we know is right
if you enjoyed this short clip visit the
dean show TV on YouTube to watch the
full video